Let's talk about calendars.
Many forms need the concept of a date.
It shows up everywhere,
ordering plane tickets, movie tickets,
setting a doctor appointment, and
probably a million other examples.
You could turn dates into a three or
four parts process with time,
day of month, months, and a year.
Or you could use a calendar widget.
I like calendar widgets because they are
much simpler, and more straightforward.
You've got a few options for
displaying calendars.
You could use the browser's
implementation by setting the attribute
type equal datetime-local
on an input element.
But, you might find that it
doesn't match the visual theme
of your app, that's fine.
You could always edit it styles or
simply roll on your own CSS,
using web components or
a JavaScript widget.
See the instructor notes, for
some more info about styling or
building calendars.
Other way, the most important thing,
Is to show your users a full calendar
when they need to set a date.
If not, users will never get away
from your form to look up dates
which only increase the odds that they
will abandon the form all together.
Here is another example.
When I wish to book a flight,
I can see clearly what are the dates
that this flight is going
to take off and land.
Dates are common.
Show your users calendars
when they need them.